in reality could a car explode yes but
it probably would be more of a little
bit of an explosion than more of just a
straight up regular fire hello my name
is tanner faust i've been lucky enough
to be a stunt driver and race car driver
for just over 25 years i've had some
world records including the longest jump
in a four wheeled vehicle the highest
loop in a car and the fastest speed
indoors today we're going to be looking
at car chases in movies and judge how
real they actually are
that's one of the great things about
sand is you can hit the brakes and stop
so fast as the tires dig into the sand
almost there's not a lot of quick
response other than braking in sand so
you have to really be ahead of the car
and kind of start your process of
turning start your process of
accelerating early knowing that there's
going to be a delay before it really
happens
if they did have a driver in the car man
does that hurt a lot of times what
they'll do is they'll have a cable
attached underneath the car it simulates
as if the bumper hit something and
flipped over but really it's a cable
that snaps and it really helps the car
do a front flip i've done
stuff like that before on a cable and
the shock is really quite aggressive
they have some tools that they can hook
up that will soften the blow a little
bit but that looked like a hard one
there are a couple challenges when
you're driving in the desert or driving
in sand like this one is the visibility
it can't be underestimated how horrible
it is to lose complete visibility even
for just a moment
these aren't really built and capable
desert machines
they're really kind of maybe put
together for art and also for some
hydraulics and some some action
sometimes like even a polaris razor like
a little buggy that's lightweight with a
huge amount of suspension travel can
cover ground in the desert faster than
just about anything trophy trucks which
weigh about five times as much as a
razor but also have
five times the horsepower are quicker in
a lot of scenarios but usually smaller
lighter with a lot of travel is better
but certainly the effects guys had a
handful with this clip pulling the top
off of the car once it's off and you're
in the sand it's not like asphalt where
when metal hits asphalt it skips and
slides once it hits the sand that would
have been something you wanted to steer
completely clear of and they would have
had a lot of safety built around that
difficult to work in the dirt like that
not just for visibility but if anything
goes wrong or when a car rolls in the
dirt it's a much more violent role than
the asphalt a very small touch in the
wrong place could have a big injury i'd
give it an 8. that's a surprisingly
dangerous scene
one of my favorite things is to drive on
the ice you can actually have a lot of
control on ice
when you're going into it knowing how
slippery it is you still have the same
weight machine still has the same
horsepower the same brakes and
everything but you have very very little
grip connecting you to the surface so
you just have to really think ahead on
the ice
when the car flips over it's quite
aggressive gets a very big pop and a
very big rotation believable that it
would come back and land on the tires
not super believable that the driver
wouldn't get whiplash or his head
wouldn't bounce right out of the window
but the fact that it's ice means that
you're keeping your speed the whole time
even though you're sliding on your roof
in a straight line you can go very very
fast 80 100 miles an hour but for a
corner that maybe you could take 40
miles an hour in the dry you may have to
slow down to 5 or 10 miles an hour on
the ice
that to me looks like my version of
disneyland the colder the ice is the
more traction it has once ice gets
closer to melting temperature it gets
more slippery once it gets a layer of
water on it so the warmer the ice if
you're going to use studs or spikes on
the tires the taller they would need to
be but
it would be difficult to get traction if
they ever did have ice with actually
water on top of it so i imagine it was
some sort of different surface
those are massive spikes so in reality
they would have been
a third that size at the very most if i
had those spikes ready to go in tires
i'd leave them out all the time
and just be digging away i think a lot
of the dynamics of them sliding around
on ice were really beautiful and done
completely practically so i give it an
eight and a half for realism
[Music]
this brings back a lot of memories i'll
be honest
driving the 350z right there the gray
350z
drifting is definitely not the fast way
through a corner certainly
not as fast as what a drifter would call
grip driving which is what you normally
see a race car do through a corner it's
really an expression or an attitude or a
lifestyle it looks faster on film in a
lot of ways when a car is sliding and
making tire smoke it kind of equates to
power
all of these cars had such different
traction and such different power that
getting them to match up together was
actually a little tricky bumps that you
get in an urban setting going through
city streets over manholes over
crosswalks and paint make it a little
bit tricky but i was competing in
formula drift as was another one of the
drivers that you saw there so we could
get the cars very close together
that was like 60 miles an hour in
reverse in that 350z
and that was one of the scariest things
it doesn't look scary at all but that
was one of the scariest things is going
backwards that fast over bumps the car
can really easily get
chucked sideways tokyo drift for realism
i think is a solid nine and a half we
loved bringing drifting onto the screen
as a bit of an underground sport turning
mainstream
driving on narrow streets especially old
european
cities like this they have super sharp
curbs any little mistake is a wheel
broken the driver has to be super
precise when doing drifting in tight
quarters like that the car is very
bespoke based on the austin martin db5
but the capability of the actual stunt
car needs to go higher than the stock
db5 would be in this case they actually
built a car from scratch designed around
the stunts that it had to do
i know that they had to add traction to
the cobblestones because they were so
slippery they actually spread like a
soda over those to make it sticky and
allow the car to have more grip it
seemed to work because the car moves
really well slides around and goes real
fast on those cobblestones
so a car to do that maneuver would have
had a strong suspension possibly skid
plate in case it did bottom out when you
come film in a place like that they
would have to save the cobblestones
because those are historic things so
they would have to make sure the car was
tall enough that it didn't bottom out
and scrape those stones
and then it would have had to have a
hand brake kind of like the emergency
brake in your car but much more powerful
so that when you pulled it it actually
locked up the back tires and when the
db5 got to the bottom of the stairs and
slid the back of the car out the driver
would simply lock up the back tires to
start the slide let go of the handbrake
and go to the gas and then have a nice
beautiful drift down those cobblestone
roads
you take a stock db5 and drive it down
those stairs sure could you do the
donuts probably not in order to do
actually a traditional donut like that
needs a rear-wheel drive car with enough
power to spin the tires wheel speed
needs to be over 30 40 miles an hour so
that's over a couple hundred horsepower
and have some sort of limited slip
differential or something that's between
the two rear tires that doesn't allow
one tire to spin freely and the other
one not to spin
as the stunt driver it would have been a
little difficult because once you're
lost in the smoke and having to drive
out of it without crashing into people
or cars that would have been tricky
taking away from you know the machine
guns in the car just the driving itself
it's done very practically so i give it
an 8 out of 10.
you wouldn't really be able to flick it
up onto the two wheels you maybe could
do that with a jeep or some sort of tall
suv with a higher center of gravity but
with a performance car like this little
audi here you would need some sort of a
ramp to get it up on the two wheels
it looks like it would have been tough
to sell that speed skiing a card is not
fast and usually you're really only
doing 25 30 miles an hour there are guys
that have like world records skiing cars
maximum speed they can use in the 30s
it's really really unstable up there the
skill that the car needs to have is it
needs to not allow all the power to just
be lost on those tires that are in the
air and then doing it this long you need
to have fuel pickup in the fuel cell or
in the gas tank that is on the bottom
side so it doesn't just start sucking
air into the engine and kill the engine
if you look just after the truck you
actually see the cars kind of crabbing
it doesn't really drive perfectly
straight when it skis it certainly is
not easy and
very very easy to damage a car
just by going a little bit too far
[Applause]
the rally racing through the forest is a
big part of audi's history actually
harkening back to their old audi quattro
racing days it's all good
i haven't seen a car take a drop like
that and then just explode spontaneously
if you had a stock car and sent it off
of a cliff
and a gas tank were to rupture then you
could ignite it in reality could a car
explode yes but it probably would be
more of a little bit of an explosion
than more of just a straight up regular
fire this sequence doesn't feel that
real to me so i would give it a six or
six and a half i got him don't worry
being based in a video game i just love
that they still had stunt guys doing the
real driving anyway
in real life you could dodge those kind
of obstacles that quick it's just that
getting the timing right would be almost
lucky and then doing it more than once
would not be that possible so the speed
of the car is very realistic but the
actual obstacles bouncing at him all of
those were put in in post
driving up steep pills can be super
tricky that's one thing you forget is
when you're on a really steep incline
you have gravity working with you when
you go to the brakes it's working
against you when you're accelerating in
this particular case i don't think they
drove up a hill and all of the pitch and
incline that you see is just done from
camera angle and from computer graphics
that jump looked real to me even the way
the front bumper popped off looked very
realistic i actually had to call brent
fletcher the driver to see if the jump
was real he said they didn't jump the
car on realism i'd give it a six but
because it is in a video game and it's
not supposed to be real i'll give it a
7. what are we gonna do
i love the fact that tom cruise and his
hand movement with the handbrake and the
steering wheel and where he's looking is
all correct it's exactly what you would
do in the car
newer cars like the one in this clip
usually have a speed limiter in reverse
somewhere around 20 25 miles an hour
will be the maximum they'll be allowed
to drive but they would have done that
just to get some of those drive-bys at a
realistic 40-45 miles an hour which in
reverse is super super fast
[Music]
hang on
that makes me almost want to be sick i
don't think there was a driver in that
car that's a lot of speed to carry that
much momentum in the air probably over
50 55 miles an hour the risk is when it
jumps if it rotates over and lands on
the roof that's just too much of a risk
to put actually somebody in there i
would give it an eight it gets a high
score because tom i know he did a lot of
the driving himself
[Applause]
the jump is ridiculously big
and true to dukes of hazard style from
the 70s and 80s all the actors do is
just a little head bounce and then
they're fine this was my first movie
that i ever worked on there was nobody
in the car they had 26 generallys to
launch
and they just hoped one of them flew and
landed in kind of a realistic way
jumping a car is pretty hard because in
the air you can't control much about the
attitude of the car like a motorcycle
you can pitch quite a bit up and down
because the weight of the tires is such
a big percentage of the overall
size and weight of the bike with a car
it's not like that you can control a
little bit in the air but it's more
about how it takes off on the ramp the
longer the ramp uh usually the better
chance you have of flying with the nose
kind of up dukes of hazard there was a
whole team of stunt people putting this
together so everything was real
occasionally there wasn't somebody in
the car i'd give it a nine and a half
out of ten for realism
that's not good
[Music]
uh pontiac firebird trans am was not
ideal off-road at all just look at the
exhaust pipes getting peppered by rocks
from the back tires and hanging down
behind the back tires but it screamed
america at the time
[Music]
that landing looked rough he just hits
it and you can see in the shot that it
looks like he comes up a bit short and
blows sand everywhere they didn't have a
lot of technology
built into the cars and they didn't hire
race car drivers to do the stunts they
would sometimes just have to say that
this looks good the wind is coming out
of the right direction and just do it so
it was pretty gutsy and it involved a
lot of just intrinsic experience
know-how to have a long career in stunts
which i respect that's a 10 out of 10.
if you think you couldn't see in dust
that's the thing you don't even
realize is that that is just completely
blind
no visibility whatsoever i imagine that
they had something keeping it on a
specific line and that line of stuff
would not be solid enough to stop it
i think it's all completely practical
the way that that card dropped off of
there but the front tires are suspended
in air and the only thing holding the
car up is the rear and the springs are
pushing the rear of the car up so that's
why cars tend to
nose over the slower you're going the
longer the back tires are by themselves
the car was just going too slow to
really jump flat
realistic to do all that in one with
that big drop where the car probably
endowed not very realistic there'd be an
insurance conversation to be had for
sure i think they had to piece this one
together quite a bit for realism i'd
give this a nine i think my favorite
movie car chase scene strangely is tokyo
drift and fast and furious having been
close to that one and seeing how many
stunt people it took to put together all
those scenes where you're in a car chase
drifting through oncoming traffic it was
incredible i think what actually went
out on screen
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the video above